Thank you to Truebill for
sponsoring today’s video.
Truebill helps you reach your financial
goals by canceling unwanted subscriptions,
negotiating bills on your behalf, and
budgeting. Download Truebill for free
by heading to Truebill.com/microcosmos or by
clicking the link in the video description.
Our master of microscopes, James, doesn’t
live particularly close to the sea.
But as we’ve seen in some previous episodes, that
distance has not stopped him from finding ways to
explore marine life. If he can’t easily get to
the sea, well, the sea can be brought to him in
monthly deliveries of sand and sea water. So among
all the other microbe collections in his home,
James has fish tanks with no fish—just
archives of those marine deliveries.
And some of those tanks have been around
for a while, so you might think that he’d
found everything there was to find in
them. But the sea is always delivering
new surprises, even when it’s been firmly
encased in a fish tank for more than a year.
Recently, one of these old tanks turned
up some surprising tentacled creatures.
At first glance, James thought they might
be a Journey to the Microcosmos favorite,
the hydra…except hydra don’t particularly care
for saltwater. They are freshwater creatures.
So naturally, James decided to take a closer look,
studying his miniature
creatures under the microscope.
He could see rows of tentacles attached to a pod.
So with this in mind, James began
digging through his books on Cnidaria—the
phylum that hydras belong to—and he narrowed
in on a possible species: the Moerisia.
That name may not mean anything to
you right now. But when James saw it,
it made him realize something else: somewhere
in his tank, there must be a jellyfish.
Now to understand why James had this realization,
you need to first hear a little bit more about how
the moerisia actually lives. An important part of
that is that the moerisia actually has two lives.
Moerisia are a type of hydrozoan, a group of
cnidarians that includes about 3700 species.
While they’re not as well-studied as other famous
hydrozoans like the hydra or the Portuguese
man-o-war, we do know that several Moerisia
species likely originated in the Black Sea
but have since spread widely—even found
in estuaries in the United States.
Their spread has probably been helped by
the fact that they’re able to withstand
a wide range of temperatures and salinities,
making it easy for them to navigate new waters.
They survive on zooplankton like our
favorite crustacean, the copepod.
And as we said earlier, the Moerisia has two
lives. One, as we’ve been observing, is the
polyp form. And the other, is this…the medusa.
Or as James named it: Squishy the Jellyfish.
The double life is a common hydrozoan trait,
though we should note that Hydras are a notable
exception, living strictly in a polyp form.
But for hydrozoans like the moerisia, things
are a little more complex. When they hatch, they
emerge from an egg as a larva called a planula,
which settles onto the ground and develops
into a single polyp, radially symmetric and
usually attached to objects like plants, shells,
or rocks. And from there, the polyps begin to bud,
forming more and more polyps until there’s a
whole colony of them attached to each other.
Within this colony, polyps can take on different
forms to serve different functions. Some might
take on spiny tentacles that allow them
to defend the colony, while others have
mouths dedicated to eating. Still others might
be dedicated strictly to reproductive function.
The polyp stage is clearly distinct from the
medusa stage. One looks more like a diffuse tree,
while the other looks more like a bag with
strings dangling off of it. But the real
crux of their difference is not in their
appearance, but in their reproduction.
Because hydrozoans can reproduce in both
stages, just very differently. As a polyp,
it reproduces asexually, budding off to form
new polyps and eventually to form the medusa.
You can see the polyp actually budding off to
create this next stage of life, that little nub
eventually expanding and releasing
to create what will end up resembling
an inverted polyp…or an umbrella. And
unlike the sessile, anchored polyp,
medusas are free-swimming. Inside its opening
is an inner ring of tissue called the velum,
which helps the medusa move
around by tensing up and relaxing.
For this Moerisia species, the medusa are
phototaxic, meaning they like swimming toward
light. That’s actually how James found them
in his tank. After identifying the possible
species and reading that they like to swim toward
light, he decided to check the side of the tank
that received all the morning sunshine.
When he did, he found his tiny jellies.
But the main function of this form is
less about light and more about sex.
In Moerisia that have been raised in the lab,
the medusa takes about 8 days to develop gonads.
And when they do, they will
proceed to their next step: sex.
The exact details of how hydrozoans
have sex varies with different species,
and we haven’t been able to find an answer to
exactly how the Moerisia do it in the literature.
But we want to briefly state that
one of the hydrozoan possibilities
is that the male releases sperm into
the water, and the female releases eggs
that chemically attract the sperm to them.
The fertilization is entirely external,
just happening in the water, and eventually that
fertilized egg will develop into a new organism.
Here’s an important question though, why the
double life? Why two different stages that can
each reproduce in completely different ways? Well,
because asexual and sexual reproduction are both
pretty nifty talents to have on hand. Asexual
reproduction is fast, and it helps polyps build
their local populations quickly. The downside
is that an asexual polyp means limiting both the
scenery and the gene pool. With that comes the
risk that the environment will shift suddenly
and both the polyp and the entire population
will be unable to adapt fast enough to survive.
But by leading a second sexually reproductive
life as a medusa, the hydrozoan gets to disperse
both physically and genetically. But there is a
cost—after all, sexual reproduction takes time
and special organs and the hope that sperm will
meet an egg. But that is why the hydrozoan doesn’t
strictly rely on sexual reproduction either.
This combined strategy is part of why the Moerisia
has been so successful at traveling beyond
its origins. It gets the best of both worlds,
as an organism that is at times static
and dividing, and at other times swimming
and mixing. Each generation produces a large local
population that can eventually expand and spread.
We should, here at the end however, admit one
thing. Technically, our Squishy the Jellyfish
is not a “true” jellyfish. To be considered a
true jellyfish, an animal has to be a member
of the class Scyphozoa. And Scyphozoa—like the
hydrozoa—are part of the Cnidarian phylum. So
while Moerisia and their fellow medusa hydrozoa
do bear a strong resemblance and relationship to
their true jelly relatives, they also have their
own unique structures that make them distinct
(and, alas, not true jellyfish).
But in our tank of sea water,
Squishy the Jellyfish will keep his title. He
has worked and traveled a long way to earn it.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you to Truebill
for sponsoring this video.
Still searching for a New Year’s resolution
that you can actually keep? How about getting
rid of a few of the streaming services
that you barely remember signing up for
and very often forget you even have? Or
maybe just try feeling more in control
of your finances in the New Year. Either
way, Truebill is there to help you out.
Truebill is the all-in-one
personal finance app that
helps you to take control of your financial
life—helping you save more and spend less.
With Truebill, you securely connect your financial
accounts, and they’ll take care of the rest.
This personal finance manager tracks
all your subscriptions in one place,
cancels unwanted ones with just a tap by
safely and securely identifying recurring
charges. It can even negotiate your bills
for you, while also monitoring your credit
score and automating your savings. And you
can do all of this with just this one app.
Download Truebill for free today by
heading to Truebill.com/microcosmos
or by clicking the link in the description
There’s a bunch of names coming up on the
screen right now. They are the people who
make this channel possible. They are our
patrons on Patreon. They are people who saw
chill, weird, interesting microscopy
videos on youtube and they were like,
“I want to watch more of those.” And then
they watched a few more and decided to go to
Patreon.com/journeytomicro. So, if you’re looking
for someone to thank, those are the people.
If you want to see more from our Master
of Microscopes, James Weiss, check out
Jam & Germs on Instagram or TikTok or pick up his
book, The Hidden Beauty of the Microscopic World.
And if you want to see more from us, there’s
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.